[Música]
era el fin de 2016 no sé qué estaban
haciendo ustedes pero yo estaba
pendiente de esto este película si no lo
vieron doctor strange mírenla pero la
realidad es que la mayoría de la gente
en el mundo estaba pendiente de lo que
pasaba en eeuu eeuu estaba viviendo un
proceso de elecciones y lo que pasaba
antes de eso era
que se veían estos números 71 % para
gira de clinton por sobre donald trump
parecía que ganaba pero en la realidad
terminó pasando esto todos sabemos la
historia ganó trampa pero la vida siguió
el abril de este año y yo estaba
pendiente de una noticia que pasaba la
nasa estaba trabajando en este proyecto
bastante raro un avión que atraviese la
barrera del sonido' sin hacer ruido
bueno y de repente me dicen sabéis que
mark zuckerberg está siendo llamado al
senado declarar aparentemente hubo
filtración de datos y eso favoreció a
trump para que fuera presidente bueno
parecía raro pero esto estaba pasando
este personaje de star trek se llama
data así
facebook es una empresa gigante y el
poder que tiene sobre los datos sobre
nuestro comportamiento es increíblemente
grande puso encima de un debate sobre la
privacidad de información en todas las
mesas de mirtha legrand el mundo sabrá
va de esto
la primera vez que pasaba una cosa así
entonces la gente empezó a pensar qué
pasó con esto que hicieron bueno los
psicólogos dicen que la personalidad es
una mezcla entre lo que pensamos lo que
sentimos y lo que hacemos y con cada
click que damos en facebook ellos nos
conocen más y más pero es ilegal que nos
envíen anuncios en función a esa
personalidad lo que aún no es ilegal es
que nos envíen anuncios en función a
nuestros intereses por ejemplo si le
damos me gusta una película o seguimos
una artista entonces imagínense si
hubiera otra forma de generar esos
avisos hay una empresa que se llama
cambridge analítica que es especializada
en análisis de datos para campañas
políticas que lo que hicieron fue crear
un algoritmo que creé una personalidad
basada en los datos de facebook
y parece que es todo según los expertos
funcionan muy bien de hecho con 10 me
gusta que uno dan facebook facebook no
conoce mejor que nuestras compañeras de
trabajo
con 150 nos conoce mejor que nuestros
padres y con 300 mejor que nuestra
pareja ahora facebook tomó realmente una
muy mala decisión con la forma que
manejaron nuestros datos porque lo que
hicieron fue de alguna manera
utilizarlos para un fin que no estábamos
planeando lo no nos imaginábamos algunos
usos posibles pero creo que no nos
imaginamos lo que terminó pasando
entonces nos da un poco de miedo porque
usaron nuestras emociones más íntimas
para generar un provecho que no era lo
que se suponía que podía pasar y con
todo esto
para dar un caso práctico donald trump
utilizó fuertemente en su campaña el
apoyo a las armas a la aportación de
armas entonces imagínense que con esta
prueba que hicieron que se llama la
prueba de los 5 grandes basada en la
psicología determinan algunos rasgos que
dicen por ejemplo si somos amigos del
cambio si somos muestro vertidos somos
tímidos si somos amables y somos
enojarnos fácilmente con estas pruebas
de los cinco grandes que le llaman
crearon publicidades crearon anuncios
que nos envían en forma dirigida a
nosotros entonces por ejemplo si tenemos
una personalidad abierta al cambio y por
ejemplo podemos sentir que nos pueden
atacar desde afuera pueden generar este
tipo de anuncios no tan obvios como éste
pero sí que inconscientemente nos
trabajaran en la cabeza otro por ejemplo
este anuncio diciendo si es una
personalidad protectora y que tenés
miedo que pueda pasar algo a tu familia
y al futuro una publicidad como esta
otra
ahora en esa época había como dos grupos
no se ha habido un grupo que decía bueno
yo le di a facebook le di a facebook
todo lo que soy le di mi intimidad más
más preciada no le conté todo lo que
hacía y las cosas más importantes
y otro grupo que estaba de otro lado
decía yo bueno era obvio que iba a pasar
esto facebook es el gran hermano skynet
y tienen toda la data y bueno creo que
hay un punto medio entre esas dos cosas
si puede ser que era obvio que había
muchos datos que ellos tenían y había
algunos usos comerciales que se
esperaban pero no era obvio que se usara
para lo que se terminó usando ahora con
todo esto podemos decir que los datos
ganaron una elección bueno cambios
analítica dice que sí pero así se
acierta no sabemos quién voto a quien en
función a los anuncios que vio lo que sí
estamos seguros es que esta campaña fue
poco transparente y que nos hizo
replantearnos las cosas que publicamos
en las redes sociales seguramente
ustedes también le pasó
cuando hablamos de datos les tengo que
decir que no siempre los datos que
usamos y los que compartimos está mal
hacerlo por ejemplo este caso en londres
se viene trabajando hace muchos años con
la apertura de datos generar datos
abiertos para que miles de personas
hagan casos casos como este que les voy
a contar donde el gobierno bueno cuando
llega a la tarde un tren que no debe
pasar muy seguido les devuelve el valor
del boleto a las personas nadie
reclamaba la plata quedaba ahí y un
emprendedor que se le prende la
lamparita y dijo por qué no hacemos algo
con esto el tipo agarró y creó una
plataforma donde los usuarios se
registran con sus datos de la tarjeta la
sube de londres digamos que cargan sus
datos y cuando un tren llega tarde y
ellos tienen el registro a la hora que
debería haber llegado lo comparan con la
hora que se subió la persona y si hay
una devolución se la envían directamente
o sea que cobras solamente porque llegó
tarde al tren de esta forma el
emprendedor hizo unas libras y se quedó
con unos billetes en la mano porque se
puede hacer plata y hacer el bien al
mismo tiempo por supuesto
y está feliz porque estaba auditado por
este sistema o sea funciona cada vez
mejor gracias a que la gente hace este
tipo de controles y las personas que lo
usan están felices ven se benefician con
el dinero del boleto reintegrado y
encima con un servicio cada vez mejor
ahora no hace falta ser un capo
emprendedor como este muchacho no hace
falta ser querer ser presidente o ser
dueño una corporación para usar datos y
para tomar decisiones a mí me pasó un
montón de veces por ejemplo los 12 años
estaba viendo esta película no sé si la
vieron juegos de guerra entonces son muy
jóvenes todos juego de guerra era un
chico que estaba en la casa y ha habido
mal en una materia se metió a hackear
con esa tecnología
y terminó metiéndose en el pentágono yo
también esa película a los 12 años a esa
edad también bailaba folklore
le tengo que confesar no no le cuenten a
nadie pero aparentemente no era muy
bueno bailando no
y un día estaba en mi casa viendo la
película y viene mi vieja me dice freddy
mira yo te quiero mucho te quiero decir
algo pero no sos bueno bailando folklore
y lo bueno es que esos 100 pesos que
usamos en esas clases te las podemos dar
para quedar los que quieras bueno yo
dije primero que seque las lágrimas me
re compuse y dije
bueno me gusta mucho la computación
quiero ser un hacker como este muchacho
quiero ser como él me metí a los
institutos de computación y ahí aprendí
este apasionante increíble mundo de la
tecnología de los 90
esto
yo me volvía loco con esto pasaba horas
jugando y después de eso me dediqué toda
la vida de tecnología a aprender a
enseñar a trabajar con la tecnología y
desde ese momento lo hago también
intentó buscar la manera de usar la
tecnología con un uso diferente hackear
la digamos tradicionalmente uno piensa
que algo se crea por una cosa pero se
puede dar un uso distinto y una vez
estaba en una actividad de voluntariado
no sé si algunos habrán hecho están
buenísima estamos pintando un colegio y
estaba con dos compañeros de trabajo un
físico un ingeniero dos cracks un
talento terrible estaban pintando una
reja y lo hacían tremendamente mal no
nos habían pintadas la pintando fueses
igual se peleaban por los colores le
ponían anda pero eran malísimos entonces
yo pensé porque le damos todo nuestro
talento a las empresas en las que
trabajamos y cuando le estamos dando
algo a la sociedad le damos lo que peor
hacemos
y con esa reflexión profunda no
e hicimos uno de los proyectos de este
año
apalancado en esta iniciativa global que
se llama data for good day está for good
es una iniciativa que lo que busca es
usar ciencia de datos el poder de los
datos para impactar positivamente las
vidas de las personas hicimos un
proyecto que impactó a más de 3 millones
de personas porque en todo el país hay
unos 240 mil barrios populares que son
lugares donde viven gente que no tienen
un certificado que habilita ese
domicilio como válido entonces no pueden
pedir un servicio o no pueden anotar a
sus hijos al colegio eso pasa en todo el
país hay un montón de organizaciones
trabajando hace dos años más o menos se
tardaron casi dos años en relevar casa
por casa en toda la geografía vasta que
tiene nuestro país hicieron un
relevamiento increíble para poder hacer
puntos de entrega de estos certificados
para que se junte la gente con el
certificado y que puedan tener ese
domicilio válido eso es bastante
complejo porque el país es muy grande
entonces nos pidieron cómo podemos
mejorar el proceso de eso nuestro
trabajo fue crear un algoritmo usando
técnicas de ciencia de datos
para optimizar esos puntos de entrega
garantizando que en cada barrio se haga
uno y que las familias tengan que
caminar lo menos posible
esta es la primera familia que obtuvo el
certificado de vivienda en bariloche el
primero del país con eso pudo conectar
la luz en su casa
gracias
y lo que buscamos con esto es que estas
estas organizaciones argentinas tengan
el mismo poder de decisión que tienen
gracias a las herramientas de análisis
de datos que tienen las empresas de
silicon valley es realmente el mismo
para que puedan hacer mejor lo que hacen
mejor
nosotros visualizamos un futuro donde
estas organizaciones que enfrentan estos
problemas tengan el mismo nivel de
acceso al análisis avanzado de datos que
tiene las grandes corporaciones los
datos la tecnología la información está
ahí para que lo usemos
cualquiera usted puede cambiar su vida
puede emprender y hacer un cambio en la
realidad y las grandes corporaciones
pueden cambiar el mundo
ustedes qué van a hacer con los datos
que tienen qué decisiones van a tomar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]